can you guys see and hear me right now
if you can then that's kind of a dumb
question to ask
[Music]
yes okay how are you guys doing today
you guys excited i'm excited
the time traveler i don't know how he
accomplished that but masha'allah he is
a part of us
he's one of us
kalam argument will destroy him
concerning god islamic explanation about
reality
will destroy him concerning reality
masha'allah yeah that is true that is
true
how are you
i'm just gonna story this insha allah
saying
that we are live so in about nine
minutes i'll send him the link inshallah
eight minutes
debate the one that's about to take
place you'll see
colombian in this debate colombia
what do you mean by clue
all good all victory is from allah
as long as we we do our due diligence
for the sake of allah
okay bismillah
i mean i mean so it's basically on the
topic of god
i'm going to be uh demonstrating how god
does exist and how we know he exists
and he's going to try and refute it will
he be able to probably not
honestly probably not but um insha'allah
hate this dude inshallah you'll destroy
him
if allah wills me to beat him
intellectually in a debate
the atheist has a pastor repeating
absurd claims make sure to call him out
directly before he goes on tangents
inshallah well
i will j mike the clam ignores actual
cosmological models the
arrogance here is insane um you mean the
kalam cosmological argument because i'm
not making the column cosmological
argument
mike um i'd know his last name mike b
and j mike if you think my
arrogance is uh what was the word you
used is insane
then go to mike's channel go to mike's
evil twin
and see the arrogance and the claims he
makes about islam
kalam is very good i agree
um there is a bit of iffyness when it
comes to
existences that have a beginning having
a cause because
there's some discussion about that but
i'm not using that
my my the argument's not based on
causation causation could be a part of
it but it's not
uh solely based on causation
and you guys will see inshallah when we
start in about six minutes you'll see
by the way if the if the stream is a bit
laggy or anything
let me know insha allah continue
argument should be sufficient for this
ignoring this let's let's let's let's
relax with the insults in sha allah
for the sake of allah i think we should
be
respectful even if he isn't respectful
we can be firm
we can be firm i can mute him if he
becomes disrespectful
um but let's not you know let ourselves
fall let's not
let ourselves be disrespectful because
allah says in the quran
that the servants the ibadah man
the servants of the most merciful when
they're
basically approached by an ignorant
person they respond with peace
salam so let's not
you know be disrespectful and rude and
insulting
uh let's try and keep that as a uh
minimum sha allah in my case against
i'm sure he does i'm sure he does i
don't see why he would like it to be
honest to be frank
will it be able to allah it should be
posted to the
the three muslims channel which you're
watching on now um
afterwards
the contingency argument doesn't get you
to a new
how how so how does it not get you to
a new until that's what threw me up
ontological
category
and you'll see and i mean i don't want
to assume uh you mean anything specific
until i actually hear from you what you
mean
so when you say it doesn't reach a new
ontological category what do you mean it
doesn't reach necessary existence
how can you how can you demonstrate that
how can you disprove the argument
because if the premise is true the
premises are true this logic is sound
the conclusion will follow
uh how to refute where did that go
how to refute someone who believes in an
eternal universe an internal universe is
not an issue
even if the universe was infinite and
eternal that doesn't make it
the necessary existence because
the universe is comprised of contingent
things
now this is an issue because you're
saying the necessary existence
is made up of contingent things that
doesn't make sense it cannot be the
necessary existence
and you can have something that's
infinite and eternal for example
let's say we had an eternal son the son
was eternal
the sun's rays would also be eternal
right the sun's rays would also be
eternal
but they're not they're not eternal in
the same way because the
sun's rays would still be dependent upon
the sun so they're not the same
the premises do not necessitate a new
ontological category
it just states a cause which goes
which goes again i mean i think against
most cosmological models
based outside the armchair weren't it's
not just about causation though
that's the thing it's not just about
causation
can you demonstrate how you can have a
world of only contingent existences
that's the question
that's the question that is begged with
the cause of the not the cosmological
argument the contingency argument
if you can demonstrate even with a um
a thought process or a thought
demonstration
um how you can have a world of only
possible existences
without it being a contradiction and
fallacious
then okay but this is the issue because
noah when no one has brought something
um even close to that yet truth
they didn't know the psr's couch and
explanation
or that the cause and effect isn't
fundamental but rather
emergent it has nothing to do with cause
and effect though
i mean it could play a part but it's not
it's not based on that
it's not the premise it's not the main
premise at least
but infinites cannot be actualized in
the physical world i agree i agree
what time is it 358 i'm going to send
mike the link now insha allah
and get him in here and actually i
appreciate
j mike being in here i kind of recognize
the the picture i think he's
atheist jesus or something like that on
uh
his platforms so let me send this
to mike so we can begin insha allah
i believe that went through inshallah he
should be joining us soon
yes i also host talk heathen
i hope i said that right talkie then
i'm assuming that's on your uh youtube
j mike is smart he's very analytical i
appreciate that honestly
i appreciate that
knife here attacking a strong man
and i apologize if i don't you know read
certain comments it um
they sometimes they move too fast
give you some tips from me have mercy on
him my comments weren't you specifically
around me it was
comments that's okay that's fair that's
fair
will he be using the argument that
muhammad hijab uses um contingency
argument
yes i will that will be
put the slow mode in comments i could do
that
uh i don't want to play with this
because i don't know exactly how to do
that um
pretty sure i sent him the link
may allah love you for loving me for his
sake i mean
atheists hate jesus well i mean i don't
think all of them hate him
um
so then while looking to everybody to
all the newcomers
i think it would be fair to have a
mutual platform
uh to have discussions like this
but i do at the same time understand why
somebody wouldn't want to go on someone
else's platform
because me in this debate i can mute
mike
i could take him literally off the
screen and then yell and go on a rant if
i want to
i'm not going to do that the only time
i'll mute him is if he is actively
disrespectful and interrupting me won't
let me get to my point because that's
actually a tactic people use in debate
sometimes so
if he gets that point i'll mute him i'll
finish my point i'll mute myself and
i'll mute him and let him speak
yes break bregandy i believe
um
i sent him the link
maybe he's setting up it's okay you know
a little more time just chilling uh that
works
and during the debate guys i apologize
if i'm not able to read all the comments
i might not even be looking at them
and since i don't have a moderator to
you know kind of work on this stuff and
to pin comments and all that
um you just have to make do inshallah
but since
it's a debate it's informal but since it
is a debate uh i think you guys can't
really expect anything else
um mike uh mike i have a question for
you
do you believe jesus existed not believe
him as in
god or anyone divine in any way but do
you believe he existed
don't get distracted by fallacies
insha'allah may allah grant me
a clear mind i mean
but where is he
i know i sent him the link i double
checked
[Music]
insha allah may allah and allow me to
not fall into any traps
i mean is yahya in here
how are you doing jesus existed likely
whoa whoa whoa whoa
jesus existed likely but so did muhammad
it doesn't make the prophets to claim
true i agree
i agree i could right now claim to be a
prophet
i exist doesn't make it true i agree
that wasn't my question
but i agree but you did answer my
question he likely existed
and i appreciate how you're careful with
your wording as well
because historical truths are far from
absolute facts in our eyes because we
can't actually know
angel we can actually know if they
happen as a matter of fact it's just
most likely so i appreciate
even your wording on that uh where is he
i don't know
no i'm not debating the mic in this chat
no thank you spartan
[Music]
why don't you cite actual philosophers
instead of
touch bug touch butt what
like william lane craig plato
um etc regarding their responses and
comments
um i don't know who that's to j
mike it's not identical however a cause
could be a mode
of explanation either way this is an
argument based on contin
it is this is an argument based on
contingent and necessary facts it's
based off
existence so no need for psr what does
psr stand for it's an acronym an acronym
i'm not uh familiar with
principle sufficient reason okay
that was fast
i was taking forever i don't know
i don't know i don't think i've done
anything um
wrong i sent him the link
what if he just doesn't show up what if
he just decides hell with it
um
we could just turn this into one of
those live like call-in shows
i'm sure that's what um j mike does
on on talk heathen i believe that's what
he said it's called
call him i don't have his number call
him live i don't have his number though
i've
been talking on um on tick tock
unless i go to instagram and call him
but i don't think that would go through
call him live mike where you at
why are you running
i clicked one button and it threw me out
of the stream
so i'm gonna try not to click that again
insha'allah
but um call him on instagram
i will try i'll try
okay mike
for gandhi is his name whoever typed it
before i believe you you misspelt it
let's see this
i don't live in the uk no i live in
canada alhamdulillah i'm gonna call him
oh he's here
he's there let me add him to the screen
hello hey
can you hear me yeah i can hear you how
are you doing is it is it clear
is it like good it's good there's a
little bit of background noise but it's
uh
soothing good okay
so how are you doing today good good how
are you
i'm good thanks um is it possible to
turn your phone
on the side so it's landscape
perfect yeah so where you at right now
my house my backyard
all right it's very nice view all right
thanks so
let's i think it's it's only fair that
we begin
with meeting on common ground i think
it's a good place to start
defining definitions um and
getting all those misconceptions out of
the way so firstly i want to know
do you accept proper logical deduction
as a
you know proper method or path to truth
yes it can lead to truth yes but logic
alone without evidence
without demonstrable evidence to me is
not as valuable as science itself right
as demonstrable evidence
okay okay um and is there a reason
specifically you would say that
well anybody can come to any logical
conclusion
uh for example i can logically conclude
that the earth is flat
without any demonstrable evidence it
might seem that it's logically the case
that the earth is flat but it's actually
not right
yeah okay i understand that line of
thinking
but i myself and this is why i wanted to
get this out of the way i wouldn't even
consider that a logical deduction i
would consider that
illogical and irrational because on what
premise are you saying the earth is flat
you know
i can't see a curvature all i see is
flatness
that's a logical conclusion
i would say that's an illogical
conclusion but how about for example
how's that it's it's illogical because
of
because you're making yourself the
measuring stick truth i actually think
if anything that's an issue with science
because it's based on induction
right um science would go no let's
test to see whether or not the earth is
flat let's go out and see
let's let's walk around the earth and
see if there is an edge to it
that's what science would do right what
you're doing is going
yeah it seems to me the earth must be
flat because i can't see an edge to it
it's logically
deductive that the earth is flat that's
what you're doing science is the
opposite of what you're doing
yeah well i mean i wouldn't say i'm
doing that i have not done that
but this is proper logical deduction
okay then
then what is what is your logical
conclusion that points to god that
demonstrates
that your god is even possible well i
mean possibility is different from
necessity and we'll get there
we'll get there but i want to isolate uh
and really establish these principles
first so
when it comes to deduction let's say for
example you have 10
centimeters of space right and you you
break every centimeter down into smaller
and smaller units
right either you can break it down
infinitely
or you break it down to the lowest the
smallest unit of space which would be
the planck length
right you cannot have an infinite
regression of that
therefore you know that there is a
smaller smallest unit because if you had
an infinite regression you would have an
infinite amount of space in a finite
space an infinite amount of units in a
finite space
no no there are an infinite amount of
numbers between one and two
infinity does exist
mathematically but not physically oh
well
again infinity itself is a concept
yeah but mathematic i'm saying
physically
it would be impossible well we it may
exist physically we don't know
we can't test to see if the universe is
infinite i'm not talking about the
universe
yeah i'm not talking about the universe
here okay well infinity is a true
concept
right it's real it does exist and
infinity exists physically
as far as we know it yes it does it it
could exist physically
it could could and does is is very
different right so
could you give an example of something
that is like physically infinite for
example
space itself could be infinite if the
universe could be infinite
could be i'm i'm again again i don't
have any
actual evidence that there is something
yeah that is infinite
but it could be possible yeah based on
it mathematics
yeah okay okay and yeah mathematically
is possible of course but
when you say for example like you said
uh there is infinity
you have to be very clear which is why i
wanted to get this out of the way to
begin with
um but deduction and this is proof that
you would have to accept deduction
because
even you and like the videos you made
about the quran in islam you use
deduction
you said that um scientifically we've
never
observed or you didn't say this i'm
paraphrasing but biologically humans
can't live up to 150 years
therefore noah uh it was impossible for
noah to live 950 years
well yes it's okay that's a deduction
let me speak for a second yes it is
biologically impossible
for a human being to live to 950 it's
not 150
950 in the bible or the quran whatever
right that is biologically impossible
you know that for a fact
that is impossible for a human being to
live that long so
unless you have anything else that
determines that shows us that it is
possible well then i'm gonna
i'm going to logically assume that that
is not possible
but my point you said i logically assume
so deduction
yes what else would you do do you have
anything do you have a
counter uh piece of evidence that shows
that people can live that long
because as far as all the evidence we
have suggest that you can't do that
i'm not arguing whether noah lived this
long that long
i'm i'm showing that you accept
deduction
of course yes okay okay i'm glad to be
established
but based on the evidence you you are
deducting things without evidence
science is the evidence that you can't
live that long
okay that okay so yeah sorry sorry
biology biology itself ourselves
right yeah okay yeah okay so let's do
something
let's say for example no one has ever
observed
the floor of the ocean the bottom of the
ocean do you need to observe it to come
to the conclusion that the ocean has
a bottom well we actually have observed
the bottom of the ocean but
uh hypothetically if we if no one has
ever observed it
you don't have to observe it uh directly
but you do have to observe it indirectly
by understanding that there are depths
you know there are bottoms of lakes for
example and bottoms of ponds so you can
deduct that there is a bottom of the
ocean for example
okay so let's say that you've never seen
the bottom of any body of
water at all you can logically
deductively come to the conclusion that
the ocean has a bottom
otherwise the water wouldn't be there
so you can logically assume that yes if
you have any
any acknowledgement of depth or
bottomness
it doesn't have to be just specifically
water but any kind of
uh understanding of bottomness yes you
can deduct that
okay okay what is the point here what
what are you trying to get to
i'm just in this aren't we talking about
god right yeah it's all about god
okay yeah yeah the reason i wanted to
get this out of the way now
is because i wanted to meet on terms
where we both
agree deduction is a valid method to
truth
um and now that we've done this because
my argument is
deductive it's a deductive one it's an
ontological one it uses first principles
so we need to
deduction with evidence is is a viable
option to truth yes
but logic alone is not because
again i can say logically anything is
true
without actual evidence okay mathematics
is like the first principle right
because you ever with everything you
need a first principle for example the
scientific method
is the principle that is used you can't
test the tester
you can't test the method you assume it
to be true right
so even induction is based on yes no
the method actually produces results and
that's what we can test
yeah but how do you know that those
results
because they're coming from the method
how do you know the method is producing
true results
because they correspond with reality if
i want to know if gravity exists all i
have to do is drop this ipad
a million times and i can see that yes
it's falling every single time therefore
the the results the method is true it
works
okay yeah so but this presupposes
certain things it presupposes that one
the universe exists in a particular way
that's a presupposition
two it doesn't it doesn't presuppose
that the universe exists in a particular
way
uh we can observe patterns yes we can
observe patterns
we assume those patterns are true but
it's not necessarily
presupposing anything like that like
what you're saying just that there are
patterns
if if you if somebody didn't presuppose
that the universe exists in a particular
way there would be no such thing as
science because there's no
um there's no consistency
like it seems yes it seems to be that
the universe works in a specific pattern
yes that's all exists in a particular
way and that is presupposed
yes because that's what the evidence
shows that's what the evidence can
demonstrate and produce
okay exactly and when it comes to the
scientific method we presuppose that
that
is a valid method to truth that it works
you cannot test it
if you were to and by the way when you
said that
you can drop something so let me finish
let me finish let me
i'm getting to that i'm getting to that
if you drop that 100 times
if you drop that 100 times you're using
the scientific method
so you're using the scientific method to
prove the scientific method
that's circular reasoning no no i'm not
i'm using the scientific method to
demonstrate that
gravity is possible i'm not able to do a
pattern in the united states
i'm talking i'm talking i mean you
misunderstand my point i understand what
you're saying
but you misunderstand my point that the
scientific method
is presupposed to work you can't prove
the method works you
you you assume it does you're the
the the the evidence that we have in
front of us the phone that you're using
is evidence that science works
the ipad everything around us that we
produced due to science is evidence that
science works
and how did you acquire the evidence
using the scientific method
because we've used iphones we've used
these things we've built these things
based on science
science works because we have we have
results iphones
ipads things like that exactly so we're
using the scientific method
assuming it to be true and taking those
results if we use those results
as proof that the scientific method
works that's circular reasoning
well you see what i'm getting at yes so
the evidence shows us that they were
that the scientific method works what
else works other than science to you
what what is a better method than
science
no i'm saying that the evidence doesn't
prove the method works
the message working presupposed look
look the results show that the method
works because the results correlate with
reality
as best as we can see and we see
the reality and experience it and
understand it using
observation and the scientific method
correct yeah
yes so you can't observe the scientific
method
so you can't prove it that's my point
that it's are you serious it's presumed
to be true
we'll do science all the time in
laboratories we can do science
we can observe science happening and we
can see the results you can't make
sense i don't think you're understanding
what i'm saying
you can't test the method you can only
use it and suppose it
uh to be true presuppose that it works
we test the method every time we do
science
every time we do science we test a
method because it
re it re it results in things that we
can use in reality
it results in ipads and results in
physical things that we can use
cars are a result of science the
scientific you know how much science
goes behind a site
a car how the engine works the tires
okay
science went into that yeah let me okay
let me explain it like this because a
lot of people who love science and
science is beautiful
they misunderstand this because behind
every sciences there's a philosophy
there's a philosophy of science and if
you don't understand the philosophy of
science and if you don't understand
that science is faith that the future
will behave like the past
then your understanding of the method is
flawed if you don't understand that the
method is presupposed to work
and we assume it works then
you if you try and prove the method
using the method that's circular
reasoning this is why it's fallacious it
doesn't make sense and i can say the
same about
you you can i can say you're just
logically assuming and
you don't have any way to test your
logical assumptions i can say this thing
about you but science the difference
between you and science is that science
actually produces results again i keep
saying the same thing because
you're not understanding science
actually produces results that we can
test
that we can observe yeah yeah
falsifiability i agree
but my point is what science is
predicated on
cannot be proven it's assumed to be true
that's my point and i agree i think
that's give an example
give an example of that this the
scientific method itself
observing yeah observations and coming
to certain conclusions
and the entire method of induction based
on our observation is assumed
to work it's assumed to be true and then
we use that method
because yes because it produces results
that we can actually utilize
in reality that's why we as presupposed
science works because it
worked in the past what is so difficult
to understand
i i think you're you're miss yeah i
think you're confusing the results with
the method
because you can't my point is you can't
observe the method the results that's
circular reasoning
that's circle the reason is listen the
results demonstrate that the method
is reliable if you use the results
from that method that is circular
reasoning
that's what i'm stating again but the
results
have been produced many times you can do
this as many times as you want give me a
better way
of demonstrating this than science give
me a better method than science
i'm not saying it doesn't work i'm
saying that it's pretty supposed to be
true
listen you agree that we all we have is
our five senses right
that's not all we have to observe yes
okay to observe yes we have we have more
than five senses
uh to observe yes but it depends on what
you mean in terms of what
in terms of observing the reality sight
uh
hearing all these different senses that
we have that's all we have to work with
and as far as we know science yes
although the method is presupposed
it does work it doesn't seem to work
yeah i don't
i never said it doesn't work suppose but
it seems to work and it seems to produce
things that's why we continue to use
science
we don't continue to use the quran or
the bible because they're useless
okay well i'm glad we agree that science
works
and the method is presupposed because
that's all i was getting at
and the five senses to observe yeah
so we also have ours yes deduction
logical deduction is it valid from first
principles
one plus one equals two how do you test
your deductions true
you can't that's the point or you can
test the deductions
you can you can let me finish you can
test the deduction
in certain instances like with the ocean
the bottom of the ocean and the water
you can test that but you don't need it
you don't need to you can use logical
deduction to come to that conclusion
sound logic let me finish let me finish
this video
i need to finish this mike thank you
set premises and sound logic the
conclusion will follow every time that's
why we have our five senses for
observations
but we also have our intellect to use it
logically to come to certain conclusions
there are certain things that
we may not be able to observe that but
we can deduce whether it's based on a
first principle
or it's based on observation we can
still deduce these things
okay again but science is the better
method because it actually produces
results
when urological deductions don't okay
i'm gonna do you see god
you're introducing god right i know
you're producing god but you can't
actually show that you're demonstrated
in any possible way that god is real
all you're doing is logically saying
it's just saying it i'm gonna i'm gonna
demonstrate why that's actually
backwards okay
because firstly one plus one equals two
right that's a presupposed to be true
because even if you take one apple
and another apple and say one plus one
equals two
you've already used mathematical truths
which are presupposed to be true
this is one this is one addition means
two these are mathematical truths you
can't prove that but it's objectively
true every time
when it comes to science you could see
every apple you've ever observed
is red until you come across a green one
and then you come across one that's
rotting and it's almost black
and so on and so forth since the
scientific method is based on our
observations we are not perfect
it cannot produce absolute truths in the
same sense that logical deductions can
neither can you no you cannot produce
like absolutely
either does one plus one equal to as a
mathematics yes mathematics is
absolutely deduction
math mathematics is absolutely true
because it's within itself
but outside of mathematics it's just a
concept it's not absolutely true
outside of mathematics
yet yeah what i was gonna say so like
one apple plus one apple doesn't equal
to apples it does
within mathematics it does but it's a
concept the idea of one is a concept
it's a true concept which we yes can
observe
in reality if you need to yes it's but
but
your point is that we can't get to
absolute truths um
is that your point right our science
science doesn't get us absolute truths
and i agree
science doesn't yeah but neither can you
just yeah
just by you presupposing god exists it
does not mean he does exist that's your
presupposition
still sorry can you repeat that can you
repeat that
you're saying god exists right yeah
that's a presupposition
basically no it's not based on no
evidence yes but
you just said that you you accept
logical deductions as a form of uh as a
method a path to truth
yes but your logical deduction of god is
not but again i actually
you forgot that i included the evidence
part that's
most important part the ability to
demonstrate that your logic is true okay
that's valuable versus just saying i
agree it's valuable
i agree it's valuable i agree 100 is
valuable but can you say that we'll
never know if one plus one equals two
since we cannot um prove it
you without using mathematical truths to
begin with
again does one plus one equal two
mathematics is a concept
just like a language you're asking like
is is
uh should we use and in a sentence it's
like yes it's a
it's english it's a concept mathematics
is a is a
language just like english within a
language
there's absolute truths within yes of
course but outside of that it does not
exist math is just a concept it does not
exist in the universe itself it's not
inherent in the universe
just like english isn't
i think that was a huge strawman
frankly because math explain i will
explain
if you will let me explain then i'll
explain math is deduction
math itself is deduction it is a
form of language yes but it's not a form
of language
like english is because we use
mathematical principles
as first principles and we can logically
deduce certain things without observing
them
for example one equals one is true
regardless objectively
one plus one equals two is true
objectively
that's a logical deduction you come to
using set premises and sound logic
and it cannot be compared to something
like language
that's my entire point the what is the
number one
the number one is a symbol that's all it
is it's a symbolic
concept it's a language that humans have
invented
demonstrate i'm not talking about i'm
not talking that's like calling me rami
and saying
i'm not i'm not anything else but rami
i'm not a human i'm not rami rami is
it's concept as well it's
it's identification it's an
identification calling
one second calling one one doesn't take
uh away from the fact that it is
um uh objectively true we can call it
two we could call it three i agree but
it's still
okay so what are we arguing about now
you're saying that
uh the only way to get to truth is by
using mathematics or things not the only
way
not not the only way okay then show me
just
let's just skip forward to the part
where you actually give me the evidence
for your god
okay okay so i just want to make sure we
agree that deduction is a method a path
to truth
a poor one yes it's a very poor method
of truth because without evidence
logic is basically almost useless
so one plus one equals two uh can never
fully be known
one plus like mathematics is separate
from logic in the fact that
it's it's a it's a mathematical proofs
right it's it's
it's a language that we've described
using abstract things abstract symbols
that represent physical objects in
reality
yeah they represent uh an objective
truth
that one equals one no no yes
we're using it as terms the number one
is used to present
represent one ipad for example right yes
but there isn't but one does not
objectively exist in the world one is
just a concept as well
i'm not saying one objectively exists as
a physical thing
but that doesn't take away from the fact
that one equals one is objectively true
i'm not arguing that it isn't exactly
exactly so my point is
if you say for example very simple one
plus one equals two that's using set
premises
and sound logic to come to a conclusion
that nobody can dispute regardless of
anything
because mathematics is demonstrable you
can i can have one
ipad plus one ipad you have two ipads
but you've already used a mathematical
truth when you said this is one ipad and
this is another ipad so together they're
two you're using a mathematical truth
so that would be circular reasoning that
mathematical truths that we've
prescribed to mathematics in the first
place one is represents one thing right
one ipad
you can't use mathematics to prove god
mike you can't conflate the term we use
for what it represents and that's what
you're doing
okay again you can't use mathematics to
show that god exists you can't use logic
to demonstrate that god exists
you can use those tools as ways to
provide uh maybe point to evidence that
god exists
but you can't use those tools to
actually demonstrate that god exists
because
they're just tools within themselves
they're objectively true within
themselves
so yeah but actually it doesn't but math
is
only true within itself yes
yes so when you
okay how many people are here on the
camera right now
again i can prescribe mathematics to
represent
one romney right one mic yes but
but mathematics is again it's just a
language
that's all we're doing we're just
prescribing language to things
okay i think this is a again a really
big straw man
because mathematically i will explain
myself go ahead
firstly technically there's three mics
secondly secondly
secondly mathematics is
presupposed to be true
as it should
but we made it up in the first place we
didn't make up math no
we didn't make math wait wait wait you
think we didn't make up math
aristotle and all those guys do you
think they didn't make mathematics they
didn't make up mathematical truths yes
they presuppose that one equals one they
presuppose that two equals two
they didn't make they presupposed yes
because
they described it in the first place
they're describing one plus one is two
equals true that's what they're
describing it as
yeah but they're presupposing that one
equals one two equals two
these are presuppositions that we just
accept as
facts okay we're also presupposing that
uh and or rami is a word in english
we're also presupposing that basketball
is a word in english too
it doesn't make sense to say that
english is not just logic
english is not the question in the sense
that it is but it is analogous because
it is in the same way
as mathematics it's a language yeah so
when you're comparing a language to a
language you could say yeah okay it's
mathematics when you're comparing like
dna for example you could also say it's
a language but
the point here is that method deduction
language not deduction so it's not
comparable in this math
it's a deduction based on how we think
the universe works again
one ipad plus two plus another ipad is
two ipads
it's not it's it's not based on the
universe we look at the universe
in a mathematical sense because when you
say this is one ipad you're using a
mathematical truth
that mathematical truth that one is one
is is presupposed to be true
that's my entire point yes because we
made it up in the first place we we
described it as true because
one ipad is one we can demonstrate that
there's one ipad
okay i'm going to say this one more time
i'll let you respond however you want
and then we'll move on from this to the
god argument okay okay
one more time when you say this is one
water bottle
you've used a mathematical truth by
calling it one water bottle
so when you take another one and you say
this is the second
and one plus one equals two those are
mathematical truths you're using
which makes it circular reasoning
so you're saying mathematics is circular
no i'm i'm not saying mathematics is
circular just
i'm saying i'm saying mathematics is
pre-supposed to be true
it is presupposed as a fact i agree
being one is is pre-supposed to be true
and you can't prove it
you can't prove one equals one you can't
prove one plus one equals two
because as soon as you try to as soon as
you try to you use mathematical
truths already as soon as you say this
is one water ball you've already
you've already failed that's circular
arguing because they're using math to
prove math
this is one what so you're saying
mathematics is a circular thing to use
wow okay i'm no i'm saying trying to
prove mathematics
by saying this is one water bottle is
circular reasoning
because math is something that is
accepted to be objectively true
you can't prove one plus one equals two
you can't prove one is one
what you cannot demonstrate on a piece
of paper that one is one
i can demonstrate that one ipad is one
mike
as soon as as soon as you pick something
up and say
this is one pen you're using a
mathematical truth
to say this is one pen
that's circular reasoning okay because
you're using a mathematical trick to
begin let's just let's just move on
all right all right so this is the
argument
all right the moment we've been waiting
for this argument there's three
types of existences one an impossible
existence
meaning it simply cannot be for example
two mutually exclusive terms so
a married bachelor right you can't have
someone who's married
and someone who's a bachelor be the same
person right a squared circle
straight contradiction you can that it's
impossible right we'll move on from that
second there's possible existences to
summarize it
it could have any or all of these three
characteristics one
it's dependent so it relies on something
else to exist to continue to exist
or to be in the first place two it could
exist in another way
and now before the determinists come and
say everything's determined
we're not talking about in the causal
chain or
i don't want to use the word the term
causation but in the
um plethora of possible existences
we don't mean in a chain we mean
isolated
irrespective of everything else it could
exist in a different way and
three its non-existence does not affect
the rest of existence for example
if you remove me from existence yeah
this debate wouldn't happen
mike would be chilling maybe reading a
science book in his backyard instead of
talking to me
but i don't affect the rest of existence
just a few things so now this is the
argument
there cannot be a world of only possible
existences
because that would fall into an infinite
regression of contingent things
that have no foundation which is not
contingent now i'm going to stop there
before i move on to like the the
necessary existence part to see if
there's any contentions
with this so far so what exactly do you
define by contingent something that is
contingent
do you mean in a yeah so the three
yeah the three i'll mention them again i
know i kind of spoke a little fast but
one no no
characteristics one it's dependent right
relies on something else too
it could exist in another way for
example my hat could be orange
right instead of green and three
its non-existence doesn't affect the
rest of existence these are three
qualifications qualities characteristics
of something that is contingent
okay so give an example of something
that's contingent
i am contingent my beard is contingent
on what so for example my beard is
contingent on me being here
right my heart's contingent of the all
the
material that is made out of and the
person that made it right
headphones same thing everything
it's contingent to be in that specific
configuration but it's not contingent to
exist right
would these headphones exist as they are
without being in this form with
in the shape in this they would still
exist
just not in that form that so it doesn't
matter what form
because then they're no longer
headphones
so what they could they would just be
particles of something else
okay so are you saying that particles
would be the necessary existence
we don't know particles just exist i
mean they seem to be
infinite they seem to be eternal we
don't know how they got here if they did
get here
but there's no reason to think that
particles needed a cause to exist or any
anything needed to cause to exist well i
mean i i didn't use the term cause
i specifically said i'm not going to use
the term cause because it's not just
causation
one you know begets another creates
another something comes from something
else
and we can we can go you know deeper
into it uh causation limitation
dependency and all of that
but it's pretty well summarized with
these three characteristics so
for example um you said let's go with
the particles thing
right let's say that the particles um
are the independent infinite and eternal
necessary existence right i don't even
know what that means but okay
okay you know how about this i'll finish
the rest of the argument
to bring it all together and then we'll
go back to the particle thing
so the the argument is you cannot have
just a world
you can't have a world of just possible
contingent existences
because that was falling to infinite
regression because
and i'll use causation as a
demonstration
but it's not just causation right so
let's say
um how should i go about this let's say
that a universe needs a universe before
it to exist so our universe came from
one before it
that came from one before it that came
one from one before it
back into infinity right it's going on
at infinitum
existence wouldn't exist because they're
all dependent on something before it
none of them would ever exist to begin
with including our universe right hold
on hold on
are you conflating you're equating
existence to universes
is that what you're doing i'm using
universe
as a substitute for existence but i
could say existence
and so i could say i could say let's say
existence one
comes from existence two which comes
from existence three which comes from
existence four
and that this goes back at infinitum
okay go ahead yeah yeah none of them
would exist because they're all
contingent on something else
so we need to get to a point where there
is something that exists that's not
contingent
because if it's not necessary through
itself if it's necessary
or if it's possible through something
else i'll put like this if everything in
existence is possible through something
else
nothing would exist
i i don't even know what non-existence
even means
but okay all i know is existence i don't
know what that
what anything you're saying but you can
continue
okay okay i'll wrap it up then we'll
we'll come back and kind of delve
through a little bit
so the point is that since you can't
have a world of contingent things
you need something that is not
contingent it's not possible
it's necessary so these are the
characteristics of such an existence it
must be
there must never be a time when the
necessary existence
does not exist it must be uncaused
so it's not contingent at all and it
does not depend on
anything but everything that exists
ultimately depends on the necessary
existence
okay yeah so let's go back to the point
that's the full argument let's go back
to the point
where um you can't have an infinite i
don't i don't see
either i didn't hear the word god
anywhere well i'm not
i mean i feel like if i just said we
must have god you would call it god of
the app so i'm saying the necessary
existence
and there's more yeah i would call the
guy that gaps because nowhere did you
say god i mean
the best argument can get you is that
there was maybe a cause
that's where else you can get you we're
getting there let me
let me talk it doesn't say anything
about the cause
you're you have no idea what the cause
even is all you're doing
all you're doing is assuming that the
cause is god makes no sense
okay that's not what i'm doing and i'm
going to demonstrate how okay
i'm going to go ahead we'll go in depth
um and i wrote these down because i
thought it would come up so let's talk
about causation as one of the points
because we know that things can cause
other things uh do
do things that no wait no wait let me be
clear very clear about my wording
i never said everything that begins to
exist has a cause i said we know things
cause other things that things
cause other things to change yes but not
to exist
so my my me coming from my mother didn't
cause my existence
no so i don't exist i don't exist
you stop using straw man's okay
because i'm speaking right now because
you as a rami right
that's a label but you are just a
collection of particles that's what you
really are
so when you say my mom made me exist no
she didn't what she did is she
she provided one single cell that
produced you
you existed your particles existed
before your mother
they existed as far as you know for as
long as we can imagine
so yes you always existed as far as we
know your particles always existed
okay let's go with that then let's go
with that
so you're saying you're saying because
they're
again and i i want you to actually
refute this
this point that there must be a
necessary existence
and you cannot have a world of just
contingent things
there i don't even know what necessary
existence means i mean
all we know is the universe as far as we
know we don't even know what is outside
of the universe if there is an outside
so i don't know what to say dude
you're just saying you're just making
these labels the necessary existence
i'm giving i'm giving specific
characteristics
how do you know the characteristics
this is this is a deductive argument
for what for the necessary existence
mike okay how do you know this necessary
existence is real
because there are contingent existences
and you can't have a world of only
contingent existences
we just went through this i'm not
contingent on anything my particles
okay okay so you're saying that
in essence particles would be the
necessary existence
they are the thing that does not that's
not contingent upon anything else
i'm not assuming that i'm just simply
saying there's no reason to think that
we are contentious or the particles are
contingent on anything they might be
okay but there's no reason to think that
okay so for me to be here i'm contingent
on the particles that make me
for you to be here yes your contingency
on your particles okay no no not
not to exist in the first place but to
be in that room you're in yes
but that doesn't matter in the grand
scheme of things you would still exist
okay so okay firstly do i exist or do i
not exist
you exist okay thank you glad to know i
thought i was going crazy for a second
no
you're not understanding you're not
understanding what i'm saying and it
shows
the particles that make up you would
still exist you wouldn't exist
in that room but you would still exist
in the universe
okay so i mean i wouldn't be romney
necessarily i would be
exact it would just be particles okay so
let's so you're saying that the
particles
are the necessary existence they're not
contingent upon anything
they are independent eternal infinite so
on and so forth
again you're putting words in my mouth
i'm not saying they are necessary i'm
simply saying as far as we know there's
no
reason to think they are necessary or
they aren't
as you're assuming
okay let's i'm gonna go through the list
now so first
is causation right actually we could
skip it if you don't even believe in
causation we'll skip it because it's
very straightforward well
i believe i know there's cause and
effect okay
but that doesn't mean there was a
beginning or the existence required
something else to exist
there's changes in the universe the
universe transforms over time
that's all we know okay but to believe
that you would have to believe that
particles in the universe
always existed and they are the
necessary existence they may have
i don't know nobody knows do you know
okay do you have any evidence that
everything is eternal or that god
made us i don't know not even the most
famous
most prominent cosmologists know the
answers
so no
okay so i'm going to give the argument
about causation then so firstly
you can you cannot have an infinite
regression of things causing other
things because if everything needed a
cause you would have infinite regression
so that can't be the case secondly hold
on hold
it could be the case that the universe
is eternal and that there is an infinite
regression that
why can't that be the case i'm not
saying it's not and i'm not saying it's
not
and by the way the same would apply to
your god
if god caused us to exist then
something then there must be cause for
him to cause his existence
so the same applies to your god no no
mike
infinite regressive gods and gods and
gods okay that's no that's that's that's
actually a misrepresentational argument
so firstly the i'm not using the kalam
i'm not
but the cosmological argument is
everything that begins to exist has a
cause
since god did not begin he did not have
a cause he did not need one he's not
give me an example of something that
began to exist
see this is the thing if you have the
world view that everything is just an
example of something let me finish
let me finish let me finish if you hold
the world view that everything is
particles
then to you nothing began to exist but
since i don't
what what else is the universe magic
fairy dust is
the universe made of fairy dust i'm not
saying it's made of fairy dust it's made
of matter
okay listen you're honest you're
again okay mike yeah
i began to exist i believe you began to
exist
how did you explain how you began to
exist explain that i was
i was born on august 21st 2000. before
that i was not here
the concept of you was born but
your particles were not born they didn't
just poof into it okay i'm okay i'm
going to skip you
i'm going to skip to the end result then
okay so answer the question
did you did you begin to exist yesterday
yes i did begin to exist
how did your particles just begin to
exist i never said particles began to
exist
i don't believe i'm just particles this
is why i started by saying if you
believe in just particles so what are
you made of
magic i never said i'm made of magic
physically i i physically
compiled uh of
yeah i'm physically compiled
of particles okay that's cool i don't
think
that the what dude what are you saying
right now you're agreeing with me
you're arguing physically okay i'm gonna
demonstrate useless
i'm gonna demonstrate pause pause this
is a huge straw man because this has
nothing to do with my argument
you misrepresented the entire idea of
infinite regression from contingent
things
because it's predicated pause it's
predicated your argument is predicated
solely on
the um collection of particles being the
necessary existence
you cannot have an infinite regress of
contingent possible things
because then existence wouldn't exist
and i'm trying to explain this to you
every time what existence is you don't
even know what existence
is we can barely observe the universe we
barely there's
who knows what's out there it's not
based on observations you know what
existence
is it's not based on observation but
your argument
i like i said you what you just agree
that we're made of particles
i i said yeah we are made of particles i
didn't say only particles i didn't say
that particles are the necessary
existence
so there's a difference see this is the
thing it's not just causation
it's limitation it's dependency it's a
multitude of things
if something can exist in another way
it's not necessary if something is made
of smaller parts it's not necessary
so if you are saying that the
plethora the multitude just let me
finish this point if you are saying that
the multitude of
these particles is the necessary
existence
that is uncaused that is not contingent
upon anything
that is necessary not possible this is
fallacious and the reason for that
is what is the sum of all particles
every individual particle together so
the summation of the particles
is predicated on what the individual
particle that's why it's fallacious you
still
need an external independent
unlimited uh existence to that's
necessary
to allow that to be why can't the sum of
the universe be just
the particles why can't that be i just
explained why because the sum of the
particles
is broken down into every individual
particle so it's contingent upon every
individual particle
therefore it's fallacious to say that
what's wrong with that
why can't the universe be contingents on
itself
just like your god your god is an
independent thing right why can't the
universe be
if it's contingent upon itself that's
just saying it's necessary
and if it's necessary if it's necessary
it cannot be comprised of smaller parts
the sum of particles why not because if
it's broken down into smaller parts
then it's contingent upon those parts
okay so what what's something like that
so if it's contingent upon those parts
is not necessary it did not need to be
and it only
the universe could be exist necessarily
by itself
it could be the case the universe is
comprised of contingent things
so what so therefore it's made of
contingent things
so what so you're breaking the universe
down into
contingent objects which makes the
universe
contingent why can't it be contingent on
itself
why not i'm not saying it can't be just
what i'm saying it's just like you're
doing
this right your god is going to
understand yourself that's not
contingent
that's necessary through itself the
reason the universe cannot be necessary
for itself
the reason the universe cannot be
necessary through and of itself
is two main reasons one it is subject to
change anything that is subject to
change for example let's say
we had me except i had one less arm me
full body two arms i can't be necessary
if i can exist in a different way
because the way i am is not necessary
you fathom the non-existence of the
original thing if you change it
so if the universe exists in different
ways then it's original
as it is is not necessary secondly the
universe is what
the universe is the first is no you
don't have a first one
there's nobody without the first one
there's no need for the universe
or uh there's no reason why the universe
must be a specific way
there's no reason why do you have
another do you have do you have another
universe to compare this one to you're
misunderstanding my point
you're misunderstanding my point listen
listen what you're saying is that that's
the tensioners
no what you're saying is that the
universe um
it can only be this specific way right i
never said that
okay so so you're saying the universe
can be different ways right
yes okay why is that an issue
because if something and this is what i
was trying to explain if something i'm
sorry i'm sorry
why um do you have another universe to
compare this one to
to say that the universe could be a
different way
why would i need another universe to
compare it to because
if because your entire argument depends
on that it depends on the fact that
uh there could be other options right is
that what you're saying
yes it could exist in a different way
and it's built and it's comprised of
contingent existences
so the universe as a whole and formality
is contingent upon
contingent existences okay so okay and
again and now what's the issue with that
yeah what's the issue with that
it's if you have something that's
contingent upon contingent things
and you have an infinite regress of that
then you wouldn't have existence at all
because everything's contingent on
something else
because if something isn't if everything
is possible
only through something else then nothing
exists
why can't the universe be recycling over
and over the particles of the universe
be recycling
why can't that be possible i'm not
saying it can't be
i'm not saying it can't be an argument
so no arguments useless because you're
that's what you're arguing you're
arguing that that's what i'm trying to
get to no i'm not arguing that this
you're misunderstanding the entire
argument this is the issue
my argument is that you cannot have
a chain of existence of all
contingent things the reason this is an
issue is if everything is contingent on
something else
then there is nothing to bring anything
into existence
because for me to exist i'm contingent
on something else for that thing
to exist it's considered something else
infinite regress and nothing would exist
so i'm not saying it's impossible for
the universe to be recycling itself and
so on and so forth
but i'm saying it's not the necessary
existence it would still leave an
empty slot where there must be something
that is necessary through itself
the universe if it's recycling itself in
its closed system that's fine
but that doesn't make it the necessary
existence it's why not
why not why can't the universe be
recycling over and over again in
the way it is it can be again you're
completely misrepresenting my point if
you're saying it can be then your
argument
is not what you're arguing for your
argument is useless you're not you don't
understand what's okay what's my
argument what's my argument
that the universe must be contingent to
something else and you just admitted
that it doesn't have to be
your argument i never said it doesn't
have to be i said specifically everybody
who's watching
everybody's watching play back playback
he just said he said it's possible
playback i said it's possible for
the universe to be recycling i never
said that means it's not contingent
i never said that's not like wouldn't it
be contingent on itself
the necessary means that's what it means
the
that you're misunderstanding argument
completely
the universe yes you are mike yes you
are
i'll explain it i'll explain it in depth
okay again
let's say there is a necessary existence
the necessary existence creates the
universe
in a closed system where it's recycling
itself
that's possible but you cannot say that
closed system isn't necessary existence
in and through itself because
anything that's subject to change
anything that's subject to change
you must fathom the
non-existence of it in its original form
and even if you say that there's no such
thing the universe just is a bunch of
particles
this is the issue the universe as a
whole i'm going to give two examples
i'll start with particles if when you
say particles you mean the sum
of all particles then the sum of all
particles
is based on every individual particle
meaning the
entire summation is contingent upon
every individual particle
that is why it cannot be necessary
you're you're just repeating yourself
again and again just because you're not
understanding
because you're not understanding my no
entire argument you're not understanding
dude
you just said the universe could be
possibly recycling over and over again
there's no issue with that at all
yeah but it doesn't make it necessary
okay
it doesn't have to be necessary is that
by the way by the way just you said
you said before whatever's subject to
change well isn't god subject to change
doesn't your god change or he's always
the same
he doesn't change what about god changes
if god well he created the universe
right that's that's change in itself
that's not change
that's not changed within god causing
something is change
is it not it's not changing to yourself
that's not god changing
if you cause something you've caused a
change so if
i if i build a house i changed
you changed the house you changed things
right yeah but that's not god changing
there's a difference between something
existing in a different way
and causing something to exist in a
different way see this is the problem
you're conflating two things that are
completely no no no
how is it you're not understanding if
god changed something if god created
something or caused something
or or cause like the quran says he calls
people to go fight each other right or
kill the non-believers uh that means
your god is doing something if
if your god sent a message to muhammad
right that means he caused something to
change
that means he's part of the universe
that is changing he's part of he's part
of no he's
he's part of the chain of existence
he's part of the chain of existence that
doesn't mean he exists in a different
way
complete straw man complete straw man
that's off topic
but you said that god isn't god outside
of space and time
yes so then he's existing in this chain
how can he how can exist in this chain i
didn't say if he's outside of science
space
when i say chain i mean god makes the
universe for example
and then all these things come about in
the universe god is the beginning of
that chain
but he's not within the closed system of
the universe
but he gave him a message to muhammad
how is that not part of the universe
he sent an angel to deliver a message
that doesn't mean that
god is a part of the universe what
you think god's not part of the universe
do you believe in god to begin with
do you believe god to begin with so are
you going to sit here and argue that
god's a part of the universe
i'm not saying what a great argument
you're listening you're
trying to argue ridiculous man okay i'm
not trying to be mean here okay
congratulations mike you're good you're
a good guy but uh i appreciate
if it gave a message to muhammad that
means he's part of the universe no he
doesn't
okay demonstrate it please how does it
mean he's part of the universe
how how is he a part of the universe if
god came down
and gave me a message that would mean
he's part of the universe
god didn't come down he did not come
down that's what we're saying
see you can't provide an example of a
message then i said he's a message
i said comments down right muhammad is
down yes yes i explained
god sent get the message god sent an
angel
to deliver the message so that angel is
part of the universe
the angel can come within the universe
yes but god is not in the universe
but god is part of the angel is he not
uh no he's not a part of it
he's how is he a part of the angel so
the angels are individual existence
the the angel is a necessary existence
no no it's not necessary it's possible
outside of god not necessary see man
honestly come on i like you as well but
this
like you have to know that that these
arguments don't even make sense
when you're jumping back and forth
between oh you don't even have it you
haven't
a logical argument yet you're just
saying that everything's contingent and
therefore god exists i never said
therefore god i said therefore that's
their existence
okay let's assume that there was a
necessary existence yeah what does that
mean about the cause
let's get to the god part now yeah let's
say let's say you're right and there is
a necessary existence how do we know
it's god and
specifically your god okay okay that's a
good question
and by the way it's not just about
causation as i've said many times it's
not just about causation
causation could be one but it could also
be limitation for example
everything that is every limited thing
that exists is defined by its limitation
and without that limitation it wouldn't
be right for example the ipad you just
picked up
it wouldn't be if it wasn't uh
defined by those specific limitations
i'll give another example it's easy
if i draw a circle that circle didn't
exist until i drew it
all right it's limited and it's defined
by the limitation that i gave it
i'm also limited if the thing i came
from is limited and the thing that came
from that is limited and so on and so
forth
you have infinite regression again so
you need something that's unlimited at
the beginning
same thing with the cause you need
something that's uncaused okay so you're
basically saying your god is
omnipotent which is illogical is a
paradox
can your god do something evil can you
god do evil
okay so when you say god can do anything
right
that's basically right okay okay when
you say god can do anything
um first we have to define what do we
mean by anything
a thing is something that is possible
right
so we just ex we just explained that you
can't have um
what was the term i use impossible
existences a squared circle
that's not a thing so there's nothing or
there's
there's no chance of doing it because
it's not even a thing to begin with
right so when you say
being evil is possible is it not being
evil is not possible for
god so then he's not unlimited
he's no that's it he's limited by
something something he's listening
i'm gonna explain the question itself is
a contradiction
the question itself is that's like
asking this man is a bachelor when did
he get married
it's like what are you talking about i
can't give a date he never got married
so when you say
god is all good can he do bad no he
can't do bad because he's all good
that's a contradiction it's like asking
can god create a rock he can't lift
as soon as you say god you're describing
an all-powerful being
as soon as you say can't lift that's an
impossibility
and not being able to do something that
makes you weak is not weakness
okay it's not again but again unlimited
means you can do anything it doesn't
matter
it is not if it's logically possible or
not your god can do anything it doesn't
matter what life says logic
is something we invented any logic
if you're saying that god can only do
things that are logically possible
then your god is limited by logic and
who is limiting god by his logic
who's limiting him
this is why this is why it's important
to understand the philosophical concepts
because when you say
a thing what is a thing a thing is
something which is possible
god being weak god ceasing to exist is
not possible
and that doesn't make god limited that
actually makes him
so you're necessary so he's not
unlimited that's what omnipotence means
being anything listen
mike doing anything entails that it's
something that is possible a square
circle is not a possible thing it's not
a thing so when we say god can do
anything
it's something that is possible saying
can god make a rock that he can't lift
is a contradiction
why is that a contradiction because when
you say god you're talking an
all-powerful being
when you say can't you're limiting him
that's not a possibility
exactly and that's you're not you're not
willing to admit that
the paradox applies to your god because
you're saying that you can do anything
listen listen your question is illogical
it's self-defeating
it is your question is self-defeating
you're redefining what it means to be
unlimited
and saying that he could only do things
that are logically possible so then what
is
so then obviously do you agree that god
is limited by logic
i never said god is limited by like this
you're misrepresenting my entire point
this is a straw man this is a straw man
i'm gonna explain why answer the
question
is god limited by logic can you do
things that are logically impossible
do things that are logically impossible
yeah can you do that
that doesn't mean he's limited by logic
if he can't
what yes that's what it means if you
can't do something that's logically
impossible that means you're limited by
logic
your question is a fallacy okay i'll
explain it when god when you say god
you're talking about an all-powerful
being when you say is he limited by
something
that's a fallacy god who is unlimited is
he limited by something that's
fallacious
that's a policy it's an illogical
question it's fallacious because you say
so
you're the one it's not no it's a
fallacies yes it is
can you have an all-powerful being
that's so powerful and makes itself weak
that's a contradiction
that's fallacious it doesn't make sense
exactly that's why it's a paradox to
call your god
unlimited no that's why it's a paradox
to ask can he do things that make him
weak
that's why that's the definition of a
paradox
they're mutually exclusive so okay so
can you answer the question
is god limited by logic that's a
fallacious question that's my point
it doesn't make sense it's
self-defeating yes it's a yes or no it's
self-defeating
again how is it self-defeating if it's
logical
are you orange or purple one or two
orange or purple orange
logical that's illogical i'm saying is
god limited by logic
that's illogical because you're neither
if i'm demanding only two two answers
purple or orange you can't give either
because
you're not you're neither okay so who
created logic didn't god create logic
when you say logic you mean i think
he cut out
i think he i think he cut out man
i'm trying to be nice bro i'm trying to
be nice he keeps misrepresenting my
argument
for the record i did not kick him out
okay he's back sorry about it i don't
know what happened
probably wi-fi it's okay it's okay
anyway
uh so sorry if i'm if i sound mean or
something i'm not trying to be mean i'm
just passionate right
um that's fair i just want to ask you
yes who created logic did god create
logic or no or do we do we create logic
so when let's define when you say logic
you mean the
means that we use as humans uh to come
to certain conclusions right our
like logical way of thinking right so
god created us
with logic so if you want to say that
god created logic okay you could say
that god created us with logic
okay so why wouldn't your god be able to
defy
his own logic
we're not saying that god can't defy the
logic of a human being
we're saying that that question itself
is self-defeating it's fallacious which
means it literally means nothing
it if your god can defy logic
that humans made right that he gave us
or something
that means your god can defy logic that
perhaps we're not aware about
right he can do something like that he
can do something you can do things that
we don't
think are possible yeah but there's a
difference between
you know thinking something is
impossible right like a a
worldwide flood or a flood where waves
are the size of mountains
and and you know something that's
mutually exclusive
self-defeating like god if i were to say
god can't make a married bachelor it's
not because god is weak it's because a
married bachelor
is mutually they're mutually exclusive
so that's self-defeating
i agree but i'm not saying that i agree
your god might be limited by logic but
but i'm not you're not answering the
question
i'm necessarily answering the question
mike i'm not answering the question you
want
the way you want me to because it's
self-defeating and i've tried to
demonstrate
a few times how it's self-defeating it's
a yes or no i mean is god limited by his
logic or not it's it's not yes or no
because that question itself
is self-defeating which means it's not
even a valid question
it doesn't make sense are you limited by
logic yes or no
i am limited by logic yeah is god
limited by logic
when you say god you're talking about an
all-powerful being and when you say is
he limited by something that's
a self-defeating statement
so then he's not limited so then he's
unlimited so that means he can he can
do anything above logic you can do
anything you want right
mike can god do anything he wants yes or
no god can do whatever he wills
whatever he wills yeah so so he could
potentially
do things that are logically impossible
if he willed it to do it will debate
that is self-defeating
all right let's move on because you're
not answering let's move on
i mean it's a self-defeating question so
i don't know what you want me to say do
you want to
get do you want to get into something
else do you want to talk about anything
else
i mean we'll move on we'll move on but i
gotta go in a few minutes but uh i got
some more time
okay talk to you later if you want okay
okay so
i've basically gotten to the point where
i've demonstrated how a necessary
existence must exist
i haven't really heard much of a i
haven't heard much of a response or
refutation to that point
it's just why can't the universe be that
why can't particles be that
but we've basically agreed that there
must be one
no i haven't i i did not agree that
there must be one i i'm saying that
there might be one
we don't know and you don't know either
just because i do know
that there must be another existence
just because abducted by logic does not
mean it's necessarily true
if no it's not what i want if the
premise is true and the logic is sound
the results will follow
yes and i i disputed you many times how
did you describe jake
how did you okay do it again because
your logic assumes that everything
something began to exist and that's not
true
i never said i never said that that's
the kalam
i mentioned it but that's not my
argument this is my point i'll give you
something
so then so then you agree that the
universe could have not just began to
exist the universe could have always
been here do you agree
it could be eternal yes it could be
eternal but that that doesn't mean
yeah let me finish let me finish let me
finish it could be eternal
that doesn't make it necessary you can
have a son
that's eternal the sun's rays would also
be eternal
but they're not the same because the
sun's rays
depend on the sun they're not the same
so just because it's eternal even if
it's eternal and infinite
this does not make it necessary the
sun's raised wouldn't depend on the sun
could they be there without the sun if
all there was was a sun
in the rays then all there is is
particles
right you're just describing it as a sun
but it's just particles that were always
there in the first place
light it was always there light is a
particle okay
lights are photons i've already apps
have always existed
and again if anyone's not answering the
question it's you
i give i've explained many times why the
particles
in summation cannot be the necessary
existence and why
even if they worked in a closed system
you would still need an independent
unlimited uh necessary existence that
does not need anything from anyone to
exist
that can exist necessarily by itself
i don't see why how you got there at all
um
that's the that's the issue i don't see
how you got to that because the universe
could just be the necessary existence
okay so you agree there needs to be a
necessary existence
no i'm saying the universe could be
necessary i'm not saying there must be
that's what you're saying i'm saying
there could be
so there could not be it's this it's
possible that there is no necessary
existence
is that what you're saying okay this is
why
and that's a contradiction by the way
because everything
could be possible that universe is the
necessary existence yes
i'm not that's not what i asked is it
possible that there is no necessary
existence at all
regardless of what it is is it possible
i don't know but the universe could be
eternal and necessary
it could be eternal and necessary are
not the same thing
okay well it doesn't matter it could be
eternal
necessary okay okay you know i'll give
you that maybe it's necessary maybe it's
not i'm trying to find out
do you agree that there must be a
necessary existence i don't know
i don't when you say the word must i
don't know like i don't know how to
demonstrate that a must is a very
profound word
yeah you're saying that there must be a
necessary existence yes i don't know i
don't know that
there could there could not be okay this
is why it's illogical to say
that they're it's a it's even possible
that there's no necessary existence
if everything is possible through
something else everything that exists is
only possible through something else
nothing would exist
nothing would exist if it's only
possible through something else that's
like a mom giving birth to itself
how does that chain exist if it's all
dependent if it's all contingent how
does that change
exist wouldn't the same apply to your
god then it's like your god giving birth
to itself
that doesn't make sense because we're
not saying god is
is contingent or possible we're saying
god is
necessary so you're what a great how
convenient it is
that you make up whatever you want and
say that that must be the necessary
existence
no i'm not saying i'm not saying the
necessary existence must be god that's
what i believe
and i'll get to that but when i'm
talking about the necessary existence
i'm talking about how it is necessary
why it's necessary
why it's impossible to have a world of
only contingent existences
why having a necessary existence is as
it's called
necessary there's no way to refute that
mic that's my point
there's no way around that okay what's
the reputation nothing
is contingent on anything else to exist
i just explained this we explained this
before i'm not contingent on anything
else to exist
okay so are you a summation of particles
yes yes okay that summation
is contingent upon every individual
particle yes or no
it's made up of the particles sure my
existence is dependent on my existence
yeah wow that's not what i said that's
not what i said that's not that's what
you're saying you're saying particles
are
what i'm saying you're saying my
particle is existent is dependent on my
particles
yeah no i said that the summation
of all the particles together which make
up you me the universe
can be broken down to every individual
particle
and anything that is subject to being
disassembled
cannot be the necessary existence
therefore even if particles are
recycling themselves and everything is
just physical and
whatever i can give you that it doesn't
matter you would still need something
that is necessary
because the particles themselves would
still be contingent
that's what i'm saying and what's the
issue with particles being contingent on
other particles
so why can't it be so particles are
dependent on other particles and
particles are dependent on other
particles they're like dependent on each
other
yeah why can't that why is that
impossible because
essentially you fall into the same
fallacy you're just pushing it a step
back so let's say
let's say i depend on you and you depend
on me right
we would never exist we would never
exist to begin with
because for me to exist for me to
exist you need to exist but for you to
exist i need to exist no no no no
you're not no you're not the existence
of me does not depend on anything to
exist
i'm i'm giving it okay fine let's forget
you and me let's say particles
particle one and particle two okay just
to make it simple okay
let's say particle one is dependent on
particle two
particle two is dependent on particle
one since they're both dependent
they both could never exist because they
depend on each other
how would they come to be do does does
the existence of this
ipad depend on my existence no it
doesn't
you're just assuming that no no mike i
want to take a step back you you said
what if particles are dependent on other
particles
right yeah which
is uh which not i don't mean in terms of
existence i mean
the cause and effect of it but that has
nothing to do with existence this is a
separate issue
yeah i'm not i'm not talking about cause
and effect i'm talking about existence
yeah and like my existence is not
there's nothing in the universe that's
contingent uh that needs something else
to in order to exist
there is nothing like that and what
makes you say that
can you demonstrate do you have an
example of something that requires
something else to exist
well i actually gave a few examples you
just don't accept them because you think
everything's like
particles floating around but this is my
point even if everything is particles
floating around
the summation of particles is still a
contingent existence
it cannot it's not possible through
itself it still needs something else
something necessary
that's my point being necessary why
can't the universe just be necessary
and like we're going in circles so
because i'm i'm
i'm trying to demonstrate how i don't
know honestly anything else
you want to talk about anything else you
want to talk about before i go my
phone's about to die
damn okay well i mean we'll cut to the
chase um
when it comes to when it comes to
necessary existence right
um i honestly don't think you've
adequately refuted the idea that
necessary existence must exist
you said maybe it's universe maybe it's
particles i've demonstrated how
that is actually not possible that's not
feasible and that they would still be
contingent
um just not in the way of causation
because it's not just about causation
contingency is many things um but
let's now go to the necessary existence
if the necessary existence
is necessary it doesn't need anything
else right but we exist
contingent existences exist
now the question that that must be asked
is
why or how either
the necessary existence willed or
decided
or it was forced to is there a third
option
either a will to create or enforce the
universe yeah
necessary assistance could just be
necessary that's it doesn't have to have
a will or
uh it doesn't have to have a mind
doesn't have to have a
intention it can just be the way it is
i agree it could just be the way it is
but my point is the necessary existence
exists irrespective of anything else but
we're contingent
and we exist you haven't demonstrated
that we are contingent to in order to
exist
yes i have okay so what are you
contingent on in order to exist
well according to you i'm gonna take
your worldview because you believe that
everything's just particles right
well yeah it's not magic it's particles
but go ahead okay i never said it was
magic honestly
what else is the universe what else is
it
i'm gonna answer the question no so if
everything is just particles
then the entire universe is what it's a
summation
of particles and anything that is
subject to being disassembled
cannot be necessary it cannot be because
if it
can exist in another way
then it's not necessary it can't be it
must be contingent
so even if everything is just particles
and that means like okay enough in
arabic
and that's it okay but that doesn't mean
it's not contingent and still needs
something
that is necessary for it to exist in a
closed system yes
and you haven't demonstrated that that's
a great logical assumption
but it's not demonstrated that's a
deduction
based on an assumption you don't have
any evidence for it based on first
is based on first principles
what's the principle that shows you that
my existence is dependent on something
else to exist
i've just i've explained it like
multiple times the universe as well
yeah i have okay you know what fine well
enough disputing between me and you will
whoever's watching the side if you have
a summation of particles that
that summation whether it's finite or
infinite it's dependent it's contingent
upon
the components of it which could be
broken down to every individual
particle so therefore the entirety of
the universe is contingent on
these particles that doesn't mean that
the particles
are the necessary existence because if
you take one individual particle
and remove it from existence you solve
the rest of existence if you take the
summation of particles
they're still contingent on every
individual particles no matter how you
look at it
it's not necessary we're not saying one
particle is necessary
we're saying that the universe itself is
necessary we're not saying
one particle is necessary for everything
else to exist we're saying the entire
universe
is necessary whatever the universe in my
definition is everything that is and
ever will be
okay and that's yeah that's a perfectly
fine definition and what i said about
the
what i said about the universe even
using your world view that it's just
particles so that it's impossible it's
not a world view that's what the
evidence
demonstrates that we are just particles
we can literally see them and
use them and utilize them okay okay okay
so i've used that
i'll call it a fact anything i i really
don't care i've used that fact to
demonstrate
that it cannot be the necessary
existence because it
itself is still contingent
that's what i why and that's what i'm
not understanding i don't know why the
universe can't just be
contingent on itself as a whole and i
don't see any reason why there must be a
necessary existence so
let's move on from this uh i gotta go
but we'll talk later i
i appreciate you having me on i really
appreciate it thanks everybody that's
watching
um we'll talk more um and that's it
anything else you want to say um nothing
that wouldn't open up another discussion
so
all right that's enough um peace out
take care of yourself
see you appreciate it
i don't know why he couldn't understand
that
but
i tried not to get angry at like some
low jobs
um some low blows but
khalas it doesn't matter to me
yeah philosophically illiterate yeah um
and that's why i tried to
that's why i tried to um establish some
things from the beginning
i tried to establish that deduction is a
viable method
he was hard-headed about it we finally
got to the point where we agreed
um and then i said we can i'm gonna
explain it to you guys
in depth in depth because
he didn't want to understand it so let
me explain it
firstly if everything that exists
is contingent upon something else is a
contingent existence
then nothing would exist now why is this
why would nothing exist
because it would never begin because the
beginning is contingent on something
before it
and the beginning of that is considering
something before so it would never be so
therefore you need something that's
necessary
i don't know why that's so hard to
understand you don't want to admit it
okay hola she's going back and forth by
the way but whatever it is what it is
so we need something that is necessary
now what is contingent what is dependent
causation if one thing causes another
thing that causes another thing that
causes another thing
um and the first thing was caused
they're all contingent they couldn't be
without another
therefore that's one definition of
possible existence
secondly if you have a limitation
for example if i draw a circle
close enough i draw a circle this circle
didn't exist until i drew it
it didn't exist till i drew it but i am
also limited and by the way that circle
is defined by that limitation slammatic
musty
that circle is defined by that
limitation without that limitation of
that perimeter it wouldn't exist
who made that i did i made it yes i do
it myself
i'm very proud of myself i drew that
circle i'm also limited what determined
my limitations
because without my limitations i
wouldn't be what determined my
limitations
if something else that's limited
determine my limitations then infinite
regression again we need something
unlimited uncause unlimited
uh what else is there i had a i had a
few more
i can go off the top but i made these
notes i'm going to use them
there's dependency if something can't
exist without something else it's
dependent on something else it's
contingent on something else
same thing you can't have an infinite
register on that i've explained it many
times
um next
where is it
next if it exists in another way
if something can exist in another way
then it's not necessary why is it not
necessary because it's not it doesn't
even have the necessary qualities
uh let me explain this if you can fathom
something
one one brother had he gave me an
example a three-headed dragon
let's say a three-headed dragon was a
necessary existence if you can cut off
one of its heads
it's no longer a three-headed dragon
it's a two-headed dragon which means a
three-headed dragon is not necessary
that's the whole point so if the
universe
exists in different ways which it does
then it can't be necessary
because it can't be necessary in and of
itself through itself
and the reason it can't be necessary
through itself is because
it doesn't it's not it's not necessary
in the sense that it maintains one
necessary
state if you can fathom it being
different then you fathom the
non-existence of the first
for example let's say the universe and
we took out our sun in our galaxy
there's a universe we took our sun
it's no longer the universe it's it's
the universe now without a sun
so it's different which means it cannot
be necessary
next anything that's made of smaller
parts this is very simple the universe
is made of smaller parts
it's contingent on the smaller parts
that make up the universe
this is very simple very straightforward
so if it's dependent if it's contingent
on
the uh of what makes it up to be the
universe
it cannot be necessary it cannot be
necessary
and if the entire universe i'm going to
say is one last time i said a lot
if the entirety of the universe is only
particles
we're not saying as he was saying we're
not saying one particle is a necessary
existence okay i agree
i agree if you remove that one particle
it changes nothing
but if you take all the particles
together
you can break them down into individual
parts so the summation of particles
is built up of every individual particle
it's contingent upon those particles
and we just established that every
individual particle is not the necessary
existence
so in its entirety it's not necessary
and it's uh
and it's uh finitude it's it's
singularity it's not
necessary what do you have you have a
system a closed system of the universe
that needs something necessary
you need something necessary there he he
couldn't dispute this he just sat there
saying
you know the universe could be necessary
it could be i don't know
come on man if you don't know then why
are you here come on let's be real
it's a deductive argument if the
premises are true and the logic is sound
the results will follow
show me how the premises aren't true
show me how the logic isn't sound that's
all you have to do
i was trying to be completely nice um
which i think i did a good job being
nice
but um i got pretty pissed at some
points i tried to try to hold it in
now i'm going to move on i want to give
you guys the entirety of it um
if this necessary existence it doesn't
need anything it exists
in and of itself it doesn't need
anything so why do we exist
we are contingent upon the necessary
existence it exists in and of itself we
exist because
the necessary existence allows us to
exist so how did we come to be
either one it was forced or two it
decided
there is no other option if it was
forced by something else that doesn't
make sense there's nothing else
the necessary existence uh cannot be
tainted by
a contingent existence because if it is
then it's not necessary
it's not necessary if it could be forced
it's not necessary and if nothing else
existed
what is there to push it to do it
doesn't make sense
if it's internally forced if it's
internally forced
then it cannot exist without creating a
contingent existence
meaning you can't have a necessary
existence without a contingent existence
making the necessary existence
contingent that doesn't make sense
therefore you must have a will it must
have decided
okay it has a will it doesn't have
intellect it doesn't have knowledge okay
i'm going to challenge that point that
that
argument that people make and i know i'm
making arguments myself here
but it comes up a lot if it has a will
then it must have knowledge why because
if it has a will
and it decides to do something then that
instills the fact it entails the fact
that
it must have been aware of the decision
it must have been aware of the decision
and what is awareness awareness is
knowledge or perception of a situation
if not if awareness is knowledge and
perception of a situation then it has
knowledge it has perception it has
consciousness that has a will
it decided and it intellectually created
the universe
there is no or what what argument would
you bring against that
what argument could you bring against
that
so it has a will it has knowledge it's
conscious it's aware and it decided to
create the universe
so now i actually made a list of what we
end up with
and by the way i want to explain you can
only have one necessary existence you
can only have one
because if you have two necessary
existences they're both contingent on
each other neither of them are necessary
you still have the same problem so we
have one necessary existence
that's eternal that's infinite that's
independent that's uncaused
all things that we have proven with this
uh deduction
it created existence in a particular way
so it has a will and it has awareness
at the same time let me say this about a
will
if you don't accept the necessary
existence has a will
then you have no way of answering the
question why does the universe exist in
a particular way
rather than another way why does it
exist the way it is
and not a different way why if it wasn't
a will you have no answer to this
there had to be something to decide that
anything there's
uh any time there's specificity
something decided for example
our dna the way i look is
predicated on my or sorry the way i look
is predicated on my dna
my dna was a blueprint my dna was a
sorting agency
for how i turn out what about the entire
universe what was the sort of energy for
that
you have no answer you have no answer if
you don't have a will
therefore god has a will as well so he
created the existence
in a particular way so it has a will and
because it has a will
it must be aware unconscious it must
have intelligence
it must have knowledge perception which
i just explained
it must have the power or the ability to
create it must have creative capacity
and it cannot exist in any other way it
is separate from all contingent
existences
and it's not comparable to them and as
allah says
say he is god the one the one and only
god is self-sufficient and asad in
arabic means
the one that doesn't need anything from
everyone or and doesn't need anything
from anyone
but everything that exists depends on
him that's what means
he does not beget nor was he begotten
and there is nothing in existence even
comparable
to him the quran describes a necessary
existence 1400
years ago so
that's what i wanted to take him through
he couldn't understand that i don't know
why
but he couldn't understand it so
regardless
um i know what he's gonna do he's gonna
take certain clips
where he asks a fallacious question and
he's gonna post it
and he's gonna be like um theist muslim
uh god believer stumped by simple
questioning well
this entire thing is going on youtube so
people can go watch it if they want
uh they could see how how sad he seemed
but i want to leave you guys with
something about islam
science is based on falsifiability
may allah um grant me you know goodness
and strength and allow me to be a good
um daddy in sha allah yeah i think there
are many people more qualified than me
that would completely you know
i want to use a nice word um
intellectually stump him
but regardless regardless the quran in
science is based on falsifiability you
make a claim
you can falsify the quran makes four
claims
preservation it will be preserved uh
lack of contradiction
there's no contradiction in the quran
inimitability you can't bring one
chapter like it and predictions
the quran makes predictions the prophet
himself made predictions i want to
really quickly
show you guys whoa let me put this down
here for when it comes to prophecies the
alkene institute has
an article about prophecies when it
comes to
the inimitability of the quran this is
it's literally 3 verses 10 words and it
uses like 11 rhetorical devices
a plethora and this goes in depth on it
and how the quran cannot be replicated
and that that claim
holds true and then muhammad hijab has
um
holzen quran preservation narrative
exposed he shows how the quran has been
preserved
it is very in depth i think it's still
like it could still be beginner level
because none of it like we're very
uh we're all laymen especially myself
so that's basically that um the quran
has been preserved we have evidence
there's no contradiction the quran
chants anyone to bring one
the quran has not been replicated in the
sense that
anyone can bring a chapter like it and
this can be actually measured
literary devices rhetorical devices um
so on and so forth and the prophet saw
made predictions he made predictions
that could not
um be known at his time uh for example
and by the way
by the way he made multiple of them he
made a multitude
of predictions and all of them have come
true and some scholars say there's only
two that are still unfolding now
so process he said there will be a time
when women are clothed but naked
go to the beach look what you see also
go to the gym look what you see
right i mean not men women men floris
anyways
um uh the prosthetic
he said that there will come a time or
before the end of times
uh the barefooted bedouin arabic people
would compete in building tall towers
where's the tallest tower in the world
in dubai
which used to be a desert with arabic
desert dwellers
so that prophecy holds up as well he
predicted plagues
he predicted the conquest of rome in
persia
which by the way muslims
defeating roman persia is like the
eskimos
um conquering like america and russia
and there's a video that mentioned that
there's a video that mentioned that
so the process
he's demonstrated how he is a true
prophet of allah
and islam has demonstrated how it's true
because all the quran i'm going to end
on this point
the only thing the quran has to do is
prove that it's divine
if you do that everything else falls in
place because everything is based on the
quran
the sunnah and taking the prophet as an
example is mentioned in the quran
so we're we're good um so with that
being said insha allah i'll take
any questions if there are any any
comments and insha allah
then we will end this livestream i would
like to debate you
all right you're away or yahweh tested
by fire
all right um you can message my
instagram it's
rami dot al khalil as seen on the screen
here
um what the drama say what did i say
christians are there are christians here
to debate
um congratulations to them
yeah so i mentioned there can't be two
necessary existences
because one of the definitions of the
necessary existence is if you remove it
from
um if you remove it out of existence
then it affects the rest of existence
right so if they're both necessary then
neither of them are necessary
they're both contingent which means you
still need a necessary existence
there'd be contingent upon each other
they're contingent upon
um each other so that wouldn't hold up
i wonder what you muslims mean by
necessary we
necessary we mean that it must exist
that it can't not exist it exists
um necessarily through itself it doesn't
need an explanation it just always was
and we need this because we can't have a
world
of only possible existences
i apologize if i didn't hold up
to some of your likings
it's different i don't know if i did
good or bad to be honest it's different
when you're actually in the debate i
tried to be very nice
um but uh
at the end of the day i don't think he
brought anything strong he just kind of
played dumb the whole time
um but yeah
yeah i'd prefer to talk to
jay mike who was in here before atheist
jesus or
um host of to talk he then truth heathen
i already forgot i feel bad but um
because i don't think he would make some
of the
very sad claims and ask the very dumb
questions that mike
asked does the hair thickness change the
more you grow it out
it depends man you got to take care of
it i've hummed 11 taking care of my hair
so
it's it's pretty good now but it used to
be thinner when it was shorter so i
don't want to say
i don't want to say court you know the
correlation causation fallacy
and say that that's why but take care of
it
the best you could give in this
situation alhamdulillah as
i feel like that's more insulting than
anything
let's not insult people please let's not
insult people
um
yeah exactly uh j m drake
i should start pinning comments let's
see
christians argument is finished too uh i
don't know
what you're referring to there but i'm
sure they are
let's see this eternal physical
existence is also fallacious because
event x at time infinite is it possible
what do you mean event x that time
infinite is impossible
can you elaborate on that my brain can't
comprehend
when romney going to get married shot
will soon
it's okay it's going to be posted
inshallah on youtube
how do you reply to an atheist saying
that the quran challenges circular
reasoning fallacy no it's not
we're not saying the quran is from god
because it's
because like it's um i don't even know
how you would make the argument to be
honest
but we're saying that the quran makes
claims that we can verify
irrespective of the quran we're not
saying
like this is circular this is circular
reasoning
the quran is from god
because it claims to be from god okay
that's not helpful
if we say the quran makes claims that
are verifiable external from the quran
irrespective of the quran
then that's a different story because
we're verifying it how
we're verifying it using external
measures which means it cannot be a
circular
uh a circle because we're not going back
to the quran and saying
quran is true because quran says
how do you guys use zoom to make videos
we just
we bought a zoom account we get together
we hit record
we chop it up someone said that allah is
the tree in the quran
oh my god
can we call it's a little it's a little
uh
a little abrupt um you can message my
instagram like i said
what if they say allah is contingent
upon his attributes
that's that's basically calling him
necessary
that's basically calling him necessary
if i'm contingent on myself then i'm
just necessary
but that's not contingent upon myself
that's necessary through myself
if i'm contingent upon myself i'm not
contingent i'm necessary
so that's like i said a lot of the
questions that are asked are really
fallacious they're just meant to trick
you like sister um
milan was saying before don't get
trapped in
um fallacious questions
because that's what he was doing when he
asked you know uh can god be limited by
logic
god is all-powerful as soon as you ask
can he be limited you've already
contradicted yourself
so it's a fallacious question
i hope to accomplish the fact that the
necessary existence must exist
and that we're describing the best basic
definition of god in the quran
and that um it's illogical to believe in
to to disbelieve in
a god-type being it's illogical to
believe in a necessary existence there's
no reason to believe in it
deduction is a very valid form of logic
that every single human uses
every single human uses and presupposes
that it's true
and i hope to guide people to islam
by the will of allah alone
it's basically saying the same thing as
a question
what do you mean it's basically saying
the same thing as a question i'm lost
now
all prophecies prophetic made either hap
either happened already or will happen
in the future none of his prophecies
refuted exactly
and there were some like surah arum
specified
time it gave a time frame six to nine
years that very well could have not have
could not have happened but it did
and at that time the romans were like
basically broken they're basically they
were basically broken
and then they ended up uh bouncing back
philosophy is an ocean either you learn
how to surf it and overcome it
or allow yourself to get drowned in the
ocean masha'allah thank you musti
for that quote by musty
you know there you know why there are so
many atheists and mostly from
non-muslims
why are you going to say catholicism
how do you think qatar and free will
coexist bro so
allah so what just because allah
wills for something to take place he
allows it to happen he knows it's going
to happen
doesn't mean that he's making us do it
if if if someone makes the argument
that if god knows
what i'm going to choose then he made me
do it
you've defeated yourself when you said
god knows what i'm
going to choose you've already
established that you chose it
and denying free will is is really
really really
um i would say moronic if you deny free
will
um like you can do any number of things
and you're conscious that you're doing
them but you're you're not the one who's
deciding to do it
there's just like it's just so illogical
it's so illogical
and people like people take their own
determinism everything's determined to
happen by
things that happened before which seems
to be a little more logical
um when you put it like that
i'm like brain dead right now it seems
to be a little more logical when you put
it like that
but for us the hobby he was talking on a
podcast with jorgen he mentioned that
um free will and and
determinism are like two trains that
move simultaneously
they work in conjunction they work
together
but you can't say that free will doesn't
exist how do you deny free will how do
you deny that we can choose what to do
but you also can't deny determinism you
can't deny that
just certain things happen they happen
once they happen that way and
that it's like hollows that's just the
chain um
so i would say that our free will exist
exists
but it's it's determined to happen our
choices are determined to happen but
there still are choices
i hope that came out right
my bad i'm like brain dead after that uh
that talk
god is not necessary he could not exist
that's totally okay
the universe wouldn't have existed so
what
wait what
god by definition is necessary so that's
self-defeating
he could not exist that's also
self-defeating because god can't
not exist that's self-defeating that's
totally okay well it's self-defeating
um the universe wouldn't have existed so
what we do exist therefore
necessary existence um come on man
don't make a fool of yourself
oh yeah and see this is another problem
with determinism if someone says that
everything's determined to be
and then their child gets murdered they
can't blame the murderer
they can't blame them and they they must
just say that
it was determined i can't blame they
didn't choose to do that they didn't
choose to murder my child
i can't i'm not mad at them it just
happened i don't think any determinist
would
uh bring themselves to that point they
would still blame the individual
i think i mean honestly you just have to
watch for yourself
he kept kind of like dancing around the
points misrepresenting straw manning
asking fallacious questions
and i tried to be nice i tried to be
patient um
but ultimately we didn't really get
anywhere but you could see
his um incoherence his logical
incoherence
um and that's why i started by
demonstrating and by agreeing
that logical deduction is a valid method
to get the truth
um but he just he just couldn't accept
that you could see he dances around and
all this stuff
wow most atheists believe in the
supernatural not this one
not this one can't they also say
punishing that person that killed the
child is determined also yeah they can
say that
they can say that i'm not saying they
can't i'm saying that they they can't
blame that person
for doing it but who's not going to
blame the person for
murdering their child that's my point
the concept of morality can't exist
there
objectively
determinism equals physical free will
equals metaphysical that's why atheists
can't believe in free will
that's that's fair that's fair because i
don't
i don't think people try and say
consciousness is is just in the brain
and that's it
um i feel like well i mean i know some
people try and claim that but it's not
like it's predicated on what
why don't scientific atheists they're
really smart ones professors
why don't they use logical deduction to
raise conclusions that we do
um sometimes they don't sometimes they
don't want to sometimes they don't care
sometimes people choose to be atheist
and it has nothing to do with whether
it's logical or not
like richard dawkins i don't think he
cares if believing in god is logical he
just wants to make people atheist
and he's he his dishonesty has been
on the public record for a while um
and scientists use deduction in science
it's used in science to come to certain
conclusions
um and everyone uses it in everything
even mike tried to use it he tried to
say science tells us
that um we can't live to 150
therefore noah peace be upon him
didn't live to 950 years that that's a
that's a deduction
that's it's based on induction but still
a logical deduction you take a premise
humans can't live beyond 150 years
therefore noah didn't
all men are more mortal i'm a man
therefore mortal
that's a logical argument it's based on
a premise in sound logic and you come to
a
true conclusion
atheists are not hard people to debate
stubborn people
ignorant people are hard people to
debate um but atheists are not hard to
debate
you can have a very sincere atheist or
you can have
a very um ignorant
uh christian buddhist anything agnostic
person
and i would take the sincere atheist
over anyone they're all basically
arguing the same thing that you can have
a universe that exists
without one single god atheists believe
in none
trinitarians i believe a hundred percent
they believe in three and one because
god cannot be divided into three in one
that they're all
god and that jesus is fully man and
fully god and
all of that is fallacious all of it's
fallacious hinduism they believe in one
god eternally that's broken down to many
gods that's fallacious
um so they're all basically trying to
argue the same thing that the universe
can exist without
one necessary being that is indivisible
that is uncaused and so on
and so forth so with that being said
inshallah i'm gonna take one more
comment
i'm gonna call it a day and i don't
think we need more people like me
i think we need more people better than
me smarter than me more intelligible
than me
more coherent and consistent than me
so may allah produce more people like
that and make us like that i mean
that's very regressive for a particle to
depend upon another particle
he must believe he created himself
if two particles are dependent upon each
other they would never exist it's like
it's a fallacy you're postponing the
problem but the problem is still there
so it's uh it's fallacious so
i don't know why he didn't really make
an argument
to be honest he just said what if this
what if that and made all these things
that are
logically fallacious so with that being
said insha allah i'm going to end this
session has been very long may allah
bless you all
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi